so this week you had the big London
premiere yeah you were all there and you
all got to meet royalty yeah I said
after you know your Royal Highness doing
all that I said can you settle this for
me
my mother was Queen Amidala my father
was lord Vader
my sister is Princess Leia doesn't that
make me royalty hoping you know that
they would agree William said
information so they're in the movie
are you are you allowed to tell us which
stormtroopers they are you kind of have
to compare with body type and trying to
figure it out I mean I really had one
question Perry when I made was whether
he's gonna have Nigerian catering at the
wedding and I also hadn't realized my
dress was slightly sheer so I was almost
naked when I met Roger were they very
good with eyes they really kept the game
and the party was in their house kids
it's a past I don't know exactly though
because they talked about the cottage
I'm like is it a cottage that we know
it's not true you know yeah so is there
a function room how does it work well
you did sort of past like a mess where
people is like a canteen and I thought I
was like where they're going but the
thing upstairs a red throne thing firm
room place with the right I wanted to
pose the photographs on there was
dragged away by yeah yeah yeah
I had to resist the urge to Nick and
astray as a souvenir so it's a big
premiere and the boy Jaeger plan were
out in force you bagged extra tickets oh
so this is your nephew yes
no JJ he's not called you JJ Abrams is
no no no did you bring everyone to Ken's
in the palace or was that not everyone
everyone came down to the palace yes 30
minutes am i with my dad was i where is
the pepper food
[Music]
but even if you weren't in these folks
you would be at that premiere you are
like a proper Star Wars you have been a
Star Wars fan since I was six years old
mmm yeah and I've really done my best to
keep away from you mark not to bother
and harass you and how amazing that then
you were in the Star Wars thing but also
Game of Thrones so like when those
people at primers see you game with
George and start they must have like a
nerdgasm
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]